and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist hello everyone
yes welcome to episode 142 today we're
gonna talk about anxiety and worry and
obsession and really how to deal with
these negative emotions yeah it's we all
experience them for sure we do and I've
got a little bit of follow-up from last
week but I think Ryan I'm gonna move
this to the right here right now segment
toward the end of this episode because
it's a big health update for me and I
feel better right now than I have in at
least a decade man I'm so glad to hear
that man I mean I feel better right now
maybe than I have since age 6 that's
incredible it really is and I'm gonna
talk about why and all you need to know
is for three payments of thirty nine
ninety five you can feel incredible what
a jerk
no actually I'm just gonna talk about
some of the stuff I've tweaked in my
diet with my doctor's I of course did
that podcast episode with my doctor's
talking about health problems and I've
done a few tweaks since then
based on their recommendation and oh my
god like it has changed everything it's
not a miracle but it's such a
significant improvement like well I'll
talk about it toward the end of this
episode it's awesome but before we dive
into the questions today Ryan I wanted
to ask you what what triggers your
anxiety because a reason I asked that
question is I'm a far more anxious
person than you man I'll tell you
social media used to trigger my anxiety
okay before like when I was following a
bunch of people which I stole Mike
following I think us on Twitter and on
Instagram I think I might be falling
Ryan and on Instagram but dude like
looking at social media and whether it
was an article about something really
bad happening that was shared whether it
was someone responding to a critic or
going on a rant man like it was a very
it can be a very big anxiety inducing
experience but I'll tell you man like
since
I have like cleared my whole stream yeah
like now dude it's been such an awesome
experience like today I was on Twitter
and I saw I saw people who were donating
to the the gem city fund that we have
right now we're trying to build that
co-op in Dayton Ohio yeah like that's
really awesome very very encouraging
right someone reached out to me and
they're like hey you know I was
listening to that that podcast where you
lost your air pods and you know you can
go and actually go on the Find My iPhone
app and find your ear pods which I
really appreciate the tip don't get me
wrong right I mean of course I went on
and tried to do that and I didn't get
anything but my point is is that now by
changing my approach with social media I
am and I am able to like really enjoy
that experience so much more man yeah
I'm able to interact with with people
who comment a lot more where it used to
be so I don't get a ton of comments it's
not like I get a thousand people
reaching out to me today but I will get
you know 5 to 10 10 to 20 ons on some
days and even if I would get only on
your personal account yeah just on my
personal account gets yes yeah but but
uh now when I so I used to see like just
five notifications hey you've got five
notifications people are mentioning you
or anyone stressed me out because I
hadn't even gone through my feed yet
right and like browse through that yet
but now it's like that's that has 100%
of my attention
why here Instagram added this feature of
like you're all caught up now oh yeah
I don't know agree on my phone but I if
I do want to post something I'd download
it and then I post the thing and I'd
like to lead it right which I'm sure
hurts me algorithmically but I don't
give a [ __ ] and yeah right at formas
we're not mathematicians math podcast
but the the the thing with Instagram is
like you're now caught up feature to me
is like both anxiety-producing and
relieving at the same time which is a
perfect metaphor what for what you were
just talking about I think because what
you were talking about is hey as I was
using Instagram and or not interested
Instagram but any social media platform
sometimes it pacifies our instead
so yeah I'm saying distraction yeah
exactly so I'm gonna stand in line at
Chipotle
let me quickly I'm feeling anxious
because I'm not doing anything with my
hands or my mind or whatever I need to I
need some sort of distraction but in a
weird way by covering up the immediate
anxiety it just extends the anxiety it's
like taking a pill that covers up the
symptoms without without really dealing
with the problem now all that to say
that we're not saying social media is
inherently bad or evil it can be quite
useful what you're saying is some in in
some manner you're actually
rediscovering the useful aspects of the
communicative side of social media and
then of course when we redid our social
media plan earlier this year where we
basically said hey we're gonna use
social media completely differently in
2018 we want to be very intentional
about how we are using social media when
we did that we wanted to be
communicative but also expressive what's
the best way we can express ourselves
and add value to other people's lives
and how can I use social media to add
value to my life and man you're right if
we don't instantly I feel more anxious
and it's anxiety producing so I wrote
down a few things that that there's a
joke that I often start some of our
events with about there are three things
that I hate I hate large crowds of
people travel and public speaking and of
course you know we've gone on over I
think 300 tour stops at this point and
all over North America Australia and
Europe and we're headed to Brazil next
month for a private event and so like I
actually don't hate these things but
they do make me anxious travel yeah
makes me anxious being around people
makes me more anxious and I do with
anxiety you know I don't say I hide it
really well it's not that I hide it but
I don't find it useful to like go around
exposing my anxiety and trying to make
other people think I think I think it's
important to have some anxiety with
things I mean that that stress that we
feel is an indicator mm-hmm and that's
why it's there that's why it's built
into us I think it is it is something
that lets us know something is wrong but
that warning light in your car we
Bax and I were driving in her Prius this
weekend from Missoula to Bozeman mm-hmm
and we were driving there one of the
indicator lights came off with like low
tire pressure yeah that tells you
something something's up
wrong yeah right but to sit there and
ruminate over that light being on and to
sit there and talk to Bexon and stress
until that light finally comes off right
it's it's useless rumination like I love
that whole bit in our documentary where
Dan Harris talks about going to the
airport and you know there is a bit of
anxiety even for me when I know I've
left the airport left for the airport
with plenty of time there's always this
bit of anxiety where I'm like whoa what
have traffic all of a sudden you know it
takes twice as long to get there and I
got to get there on time and that is
very useful anxiety to a certain extent
uh-huh but when we get stuck in the
rumination yes I think that's where
anxiety is is definitely hurtful and
then the other thing too which I'm
totally guilty of this is like for
example with social media like I know
that that has a big chance it used to
have a big chance of causing me distress
so I did I was doing two things wrong a
I kept looking at it so I kept I kept
inducing that anxiety I knew I had a
chance of inducing anxiety and the other
thing is I
I just wasn't using it as deliberate as
I should have all right so I wrote down
this note that goes along with exactly
what you're saying here I don't know
where it would fit in in the podcast but
this is the perfect time I wrote down if
you go searching for anxiety you will
find it oh yeah and I think that there
are in the sources of things that
statement just made me a little anxious
because I know there's something there
like all of a sudden like I'm like oh
crap like I got to move out of my
apartment in 30 days and I had a place
so I told my landlord I was leaving but
now I don't have a place right like
there's always something and then you
start going to like the worst-case
scenario right oh my god I'm leaving for
dude I really am getting anxious about
this just thinking about it
right going on tour not gonna be back
till the 29th I have only two weeks to
look for a place oh my god yeah so
you're getting ready to move you found
the apartment but then someone
put in a better offer than you and all
of a sudden now you are you're living in
the studio now yeah it's great though
the floors here are really clean think
about that as an option we have my
storage unit you were telling me about
what else makes me so if people make me
you know I don't actually hate these
these things they make me anxious right
drabble makes me anxious and we're
recording this right before we go on the
simply southern tour by the time this
comes out we will have already been in
Birmingham and Louisville and I think
tonight will be if you're listening to
this the day it comes out tonight will
be Nashville with with Rachael Cruz but
we were going to go travel and I get
anxiety just thinking about in fact I
was flying to Montana last but last week
and like that made me anxious I just
just did not a lot of anxiety but enough
that I'm like oh oh I this is a warning
sign this is some sort of indicator
light right and then the question then
is do I just leave that indicator light
on and and just continue to worry about
it or do I do something about it
here a few other things that make me
anxious stress me out more than one cup
on the table that's true none of me so I
have OCD right I mean like a doctor
actually told me I have OCD but I don't
need a doctor to tell me that I walked
down 49 steps from the parking garage
this morning literally to get here right
there is an office on the other side of
us where a guy has six pins on his desk
this morning and I'm like what is he
doing why doesn't he have three that's
the perfect number everyone knows the
appropriate number of 10 no it's so like
I noticed these things I'm Way more
obsessive than I am compulsive but I
just noticed these things and so
something else that really makes me
anxious is parenting hmm I realized that
you know especially this week Ella was
being a bit of a handful and she can be
really fun and and your Rob Bell says
your your first job as a parent is to
enjoy your kids
to me that is like my biggest aspiration
in life is to find ways to to enjoy Ella
as a as a human being and as a child and
I was able to do that last night you
know we had to go get money for the the
laundry machine so Leia give her a $20
bill to get quarters out she thinks
she's hit the slot machine jackpot and
so and she loves him we were like
looking at the lights outside our window
and she was like that one's pink and
I'll be able to enjoy her from time to
time but then there are the times where
you're able to enjoy it from time to
time yeah that's good yeah but there are
times like in the same hour where I'm
like oh you're not listening and like
it's truly why are you acting like
you're five right
it's truly anxiety-producing for me it's
at the point where it's like I'm
overwhelmed with with anxiety and so if
people make me anxious travel makes me
anxious parenting makes me anxious
public speaking makes me anxious clutter
makes me anxious for sure but we just
talked about the pins or whatever but
but yeah in my own in my own space is
especially the spaces that I have
control over we were just going through
this earlier I'm like hey can we put
away that lens cap and can we put away
Ryan's good laptop which they weren't
bothering anyone they weren't ugly or
anything but these are just things that
that bother me
debt debt really stresses me out
thankfully I haven't had debt in a long
time that is god that's probably when I
think about all the stresses in my life
I think debt is by far the biggest
stress I've ever put on myself I can't
think of anything else it's like that's
a good one man yeah and it's the thing
about debt is you you just said it
perfectly it's the thing that we put on
ourselves oh yeah yes someone else
generally doesn't pour debt on you there
can be sort of medical it's illegal for
here Josh I just bought you a house
here's the team $400,000 in debt grab
your hair babies make you sign them
right yeah and so so debt is really
stressful and and it was a stressor it
was a low-level stressor because I just
sort of ignored that that warning light
was on my entire
1yz and then obviously in my early 30s
until I got out of debt
31 32 and and that light was just there
and you can't ignore it because it's
flashing all the time yeah and so you
just sort of pretend it's not there it
becomes part of your everyday exists as
flash flash flash flash I used to tell
myself cuz someone had told someone had
told me you know it's good to have a
little bit of stress and that's what I
would tell myself when I felt that
indicator and with the net yeah it's
like oh I'm supposed to have a little
bit of stress in my life yeah but in an
you know there are the majority of the
people living in the United States are
in debt so you know I'm not saying that
uh if you have that like you know it's
this is such a touchy subject for me man
because what I want to say is is yes we
put it on ourselves yes and the amount
of debt that I had that was giving me
anxiety it was too much debt and yes I
should have been an indicator for me to
like to change it yeah I think most
people United States either have that or
have had that at some point in time yeah
and if you have debt you're broke I mean
that there's no other way to really say
it if there's means you can't afford the
thing they see you're much more direct
when it comes to the debt than I but
here's but here I'm saying this in a
loving way like the way the way I would
say it's Ella when she's 15 or 16 and I
would say hey if you have a debt you're
broke but here's here's the good news
we've all been broke or broken at some
period in time
that's okay what's not okay is to
continue to be broke or broken without a
plan to get out of that brokenness that
that we are experiencing and so being in
debt can be okay if you have a plan to
get out of there's no such thing as good
debt and always say that repeatedly I
can't wait to talk to Chris and Anthony
and Rachel about this because I know hey
they'll agree but their money experts
and they'll have a lot more to say about
the topic in a way that's way more
articulate than I can articulate it
extemporaneously but I I think that but
by realizing that there is this anxiety
whether it is with the clutter or with
parenting or with travel or with debt
whatever it might be
st
detests those really give me anxiety
it's like the worst anxiety yeah even
though even though like I mean now it's
okay cuz like we're monogamous but yeah
right you know what though that's not
true um I mean it's true the woman ah I
didn't realize you and Becks had an
arrangement man I mean we'll talk about
that in a separate episode but it's it's
more arranged than you might think but
anyway there's when I look at STD
testing like I had to do I was re up in
my life insurance then they send you to
go do all the blood tests and whatever
and I have no reason to think I would
have any sort of I mean I've done so
many blood tests over the last three
years but even then I'm like waiting to
get it back and I'm like what if they
missed it all the other 17 times I've
had Nestor only this things are only
99.9% accurate right and I went from one
of the point one for saying yeah but
it's it is true like that those little
things will cause stress for ya whatever
reason absolutely man and so so so how
do you deal with stress so so I think
the with these anxiety producing things
the reason I don't show it outwardly as
much in fact when I do show it hourly it
usually comes off as annoyance and so
people will often think I'm annoyed by
things it's really because I'm anxious
inside right but I I work hard to not
show what outwardly because that just
makes other people anxious I don't know
and that's not what I want is that if I
ask myself what's my desired outcome
well I really want everyone else in the
room to be anxious too that's gonna help
my anxiety no of course not that's gonna
make my anxiety worse imagine if
everyone around you is super super
anxious all of a sudden you're gonna
even be more anxious even if you didn't
start out anxious you're gonna have a
heightened sense of anxiety and so for
me it's about it's what you have one of
two options there you can remove the a
the the thing that produces your anxiety
and you can become an agoraphobe and
lock yourself in your house and then
you're still I mean there are the most
anxious people in the world still are
the people who are agoraphobe right and
I could totally see myself going toward
that you know like the Howard Hughes
thing he was the total or gorath oh
right and it so that's one option is
okay well I'll never travel over again
okay I'll stop being a parent
I'm gonna have to leave backs and and no
more parenting for Ella because she just
stresses me out too much I'm too anxious
with that and so I'm gonna get rid of
that with clutter well you know what I'm
just going going to have to not own
anything at all in my life because
anything that I own is going to make me
anxious I'm never gonna speak in public
again because that's gonna make me
anxious so that's one way to try to deal
with anxiety that's not the best way to
do it well yeah if you will a at that
point you'd be setting the expectation
that you're gonna live your life
stress-free or a free of anxiety right
and that's just that's a really bad
expectation yes and so some stress or
some anxiety is really useful those are
those indicator lights that you talked
about and so for me when I start feeling
anxious about something it means I need
to take action I need to I need to be
brave enough to lean into this and
figure out what is actually making me
anxious about parenting what is actually
making me anxious about travel and then
how do I deal with that what is actually
wrong with the car when we were in
Montana and that light came on you know
what it was actually a bad indicator
light and so so it wasn't we so what a
metaphor do because sometimes were born
with bad indicator lights exactly and so
I got out of it we pulled over the side
of i-90 and I got out I checked all the
tires make sure there was no no problem
or the sensor would it was a bad
indicator sensor either sensor was off
right yeah yeah the the sensor was often
so what I did was I went around I
checked all of the the lights and error
the tires and they were all fine and
then we stopped a few miles down the
road again and check to make sure
everything was okay and eventually the
light went off but now that all that
tells me is hey we can need to go to the
Toyota dealership and they have to reset
the sensor or maybe replace the sensor
yeah and so how do we replace our
sensors and our own lives is I think the
thing we want to talk about with these
folks today you want to dump in a jump
into these voicemails let's dump into
unless
alright let's go ahead and jump into
these voicemails our first voicemail is
from Fallon and Marietta California I
was listening to your decoration episode
and it really hit me that I think I
think those belongings are what adding
to my foreveralone priority list and I'm
a high anxiety person and I'm pretty
busy I have a two-year-old toddler who
has a lot of stuff I have a husband
who's a mechanic who has a lot of stuff
I'm a teacher I have a lot of stuff
empty high anxiety I feel like
everything is on my priority list
everything from getting my dogs he's
clean and being a good owner to you know
teaching my kids and I just wanted to
find out what I do to maybe help my
anxiety it can't help me progress in
getting rid of obvious bang without
totally losing my mind I might kind of
like wanting to go on leave from work so
I stay in my house and forth through
everything and just throw everything
away for a week so I just wanted to find
out if maybe there was a better way to
do that or a better way to actually
prioritize things without thinking
everything is top priority now right I
was a little bit worried when she said
I'm thinking about taking a leave of
absence from my work so I could stay at
home and she had like this little pause
there mmm and it was just was the
agoraphobe thing that I was talking
about but then she said I want to stay
home for a week so it sounds like maybe
she has a plan to deal with some of this
excess stuff that's going on in her life
yeah or in her life but but their lives
her family's life her husband and and
her kid and obviously she's a teacher
and so she has to deal with a certain
amount of things now she talked about
many of the belongings being a priority
in her life and the thing that I want to
stress here is I think belongings are
rarely a true priority
I think what she was saying was all of
her possessions so it started with the
decorations right but then she talked
about her husband saw her stuff her kids
stuff like everything that is stressing
her out she feels like there
her priorities yes but she has so many
priorities okay that it's it's it's
producing this anxiety in her life right
and so I mean obviously if you go if you
go back to the root of the word priority
and Greg McEwan talks about this in his
book essentialism we didn't have a
plural for the word priority until the
20th century it literally means the
first thing right you can't have a
hundred the first things right it just
doesn't even work grammatically right
and so having having a hundred
priorities means I have no priorities at
all I don't have a priority right and I
think ultimately she needs to she said I
have a very busy life and and the thing
I wrote down here Ryan is busy does not
mix with anxiety and I've learned that
in my own life hmm in fact I was talking
about doctor on the fie called me up and
he was like hey man can I bother you I
know you're really busy and I was like
how dare you don't you say that to me
that's the worst four-letter word in the
English language is busy because really
all that means is your life is out of
control and here's the good news
Fallon I think that you've identified
the fact that hey you know what
your life is really busy it's out of
control right now exactly your life is
out of control and you've identified
that because quite often we don't know
we're out of control until we're like
spinning off the road and it's too late
we're already headed into the crash the
news for you Fallon is yeah you are
headed it toward a crash and it's gonna
happen unless you course-correct
now but that's the good news you haven't
crashed yet the best time the course
correct is before the crash yeah the
anxiety that you're feeling right now
Fallon is is in regards to you've got to
take action towards this stuff mm-hmm it
is obviously while you're calling and
talking about how it's causing anxiety
so if it's affecting you to the point
where you're calling us it's probably
affecting how your attitude when you're
running or kids when you're running your
husband so how did she get out of this
Josh how does she how does she
prioritize her priorities two things
number one is I think you have to
realize that not everything is equal and
that's my biggest problem like I will
have a task
and it can have a hundred priorities on
it right I got 100 priorities in my task
list and I'll just start going through
them and I'll usually go toward the
thing that is easiest first why because
we we tend to go toward the path of
least resistance the easiest things are
usually the least meaningful things
though and so if I have a hundred things
and eighty of them are easy I'll never
get to the twenty things that are
actually meaningful or productive or
something that truly adds value to my
life because I'm so focused on well I
gotta check email gotta gotta make sure
you're all caught up on Instagram
whatever it is like I'm just so focused
on let's get that off the list get that
off the list get that off the list the
thing is you can actually get a lot of
those things off your list by saying no
to them and so that's the second thing
we have to get better at saying no and
and I'm really good at saying no except
here's the problem for me I have a hard
time saying no to the people closest to
me Ryan to Bex and to you I want because
I really care about you I want to please
you I want to be able to say yes now
it's better for me to say yes to you
then it would be some stranger on the
street hey can I spend three hours of
your time talking to you about blogging
I mean I'd love to but I don't have
infinite resources I don't have the
infinite time so I'd love to say yes to
you before someone like that but
sometimes when I'm saying yes to you or
Bex that means I'm saying no to to
myself and I'll give you an example from
from yesterday Bex likes me to pick her
up from the airport her and Ella we're
flying in yesterday and for me to go to
LAX is about a three hour trip there and
back what time were they landing six
o'clock oh my god yeah yeah so could
have turned into a four hour trip yeah
and I
I often almost always say yes I can
count on one hand with three digits left
how many times I've said no to that
yesterday was what I had to say no to to
them and say hey can you just please get
an uber because I had so I was preparing
for this podcast there's all kinds of
irony and being extra anxious preparing
for anxiety podcast but and so
I had a lot of things to do yesterday to
prepare for today and tonight we're
doing some filming and I was preparing
for that and and I had to call a bunch
of people yeah so there was all kind of
stuff going on so I just had to say no I
don't have time to spend three or four
hours and which is fine but then on the
uber ride home backs texts me and she's
like hey can you go pick me up some
Chipotle's so that we're you know by the
time L and I get home we'll have to have
dinner there and I'm like okay yeah I
mean yes because I don't I'm afraid to
say no to you
yeah so I said yes and it totally like
increased my anxiety levels again
because I'm like I'm in the middle of
doing this stuff that I perceive to be
important and and meaningful and but
it's also meaningful to provide food for
Ella and backs are coming home but I
should have said no and here's here's
what you can do why don't you you could
do a poor eats you could do you have it
delivered right to the house if you want
there's technology involved so that I
don't have to spend 45 minutes to an
hour going to get you something to eat
yeah right and break that that whole
flow and so instead of just ignoring it
and letting that fester let my anxiety
get higher Beck's and I had a brief
conversation about it and she's like I'm
so sorry you know I didn't think about
it I should have I should have thought
that way I said yeah I should have
thought that way too I should have said
no I said hey can you can you do this
and so next time we know and so it's
really about adjusting accordingly so
getting better at saying no how do you
build that muscle you continue to do it
every single day and you'll fail like I
failed yesterday but you'll learn
something from it and you'll move
forward accordingly what a great example
for Fallon man because relying on her
partner relying on her husband for help
that's huge I mean Fallon you know
here's what I would do if I was you so
everything you said I totally agree the
thing that I would add is you've got to
get clear on what it is that you want to
get done Fallon so write down everything
that you want to get done on a list do
not prioritize it which is more
important what is it more important to
just write it all down so at least you
know what you need to get done and then
go to your husband and then say hey
honey here are the things that are
really really stressing me out yeah and
I know that I've got a problem
that this is stressing me out but you're
such an amazing husband that I know that
you're gonna go out of your way to help
me take care of these things and if you
don't actually help me take care of
these things I know you're at least
going to support me taking care of these
things because you're such a great
husband and oh by the way when you look
at this list what do you what stands out
to you what what is the most important
thing to you does any of this stuff
stress you out as well and kind of
approach it from you know like a team
aspect I think as you're looking at that
as a team you'll look at that list maybe
there's 20 things on there for me this
morning I was going through through my I
don't have a to-do list I have a today
list and then I have a some day list and
like that's how I prioritize and so I
was looking at that today list and there
were four things on it and I'm like okay
is it what if just in a hypothetical
world I deleted half of these mmm would
the world keep spinning with my life be
okay if I didn't do any of these things
and the truth was there was one thing
for sure I could just remove immediately
and and my life was still fine in fact I
feel good now because I've removed that
responsibility that anxiety inducing
responsibility then that allows me to
focus on the other two or three things
that are truly important and so
sometimes you don't even have to say can
you help me out with this before you
even get to that you can say I'm gonna
instantly say no to these things that
aren't important I pretended they were
important that I treated them as if they
were just as important as these other
truly important things but they're not
that at all they're they're worth
deleting yeah so Fallon come up with a
plan like I said write down everything
that you need to to accomplish go to
your husband and ask him to help you
come up with a plan but you know here's
the thing Fallon is it sounds like
you've got a lot of a lot of things on
your plate and yes I agree she should
probably maybe take a couple of these
things off the plate if if possible
right but ultimately to get where you
want to be Fallon it's gonna take a lot
of work and as Josh and I always say
simple is not easy yeah simple as simple
is really really difficult in fact easy
is just continuing to ignore these
priorities and to continue letting
things build up and to continue to go
with the flow and
easy can be anxiety-producing from yeah
absolutely for me like if i just starts
focused on the easy things to do
it means I'm letting I'm putting in the
back burner of the things that should be
the most important to me so going with
easy well maybe in the short term
distract you like the Instagram thing we
were talking about earlier but but long
term it's just going to increase your
anxiety now talking about a plan she
said well what do I take a week off work
and do the things I wanna do that might
that might work for you but realize that
even if you clear your plate completely
there's gonna be new things that come on
to the plate and that's okay I mean
because the opposite is you have nothing
on your plate ever and that sounds to me
like a not a life well-lived at all yeah
I don't honestly I don't
I am totally unbiased to a Fallon's plan
whatever plan she comes up with I
support but she's got to come up with a
plan right a plan that that will
actually address the issues as opposed
if taking a week off work would be great
if you just wanted to quit work
altogether so you can stay at home and
constantly reorganize your possessions
that would be a bad plan so a plan that
is actually going to feel meaningful to
you see what else I got here she said I
feel like I will lose my mind I wish she
said it's just something about getting
rid of these things if she feels like
she doesn't get rid of them how can I
develop a plan to get rid of things
without losing my mind
is I think what what she said and for me
is like what you might lose your mind if
you don't come up with a plan to get rid
well I think what she's really saying is
is she doesn't even know where to start
with a plan mm-hmm and maybe that's why
she feels like she's she's losing her
mind is because there's so much doesn't
even know where to begin
yeah and found it doesn't matter where
you begin it really doesn't just start
somewhere
yeah come up with a plan and start
working the plan otherwise yeah you are
gonna lose your mind for sure well
Fallon I'd love to send you a copy of
our book essential it's an essay
collection 150 essays about intentional
living I think there are two maybe three
chapters you're really fine valuable
there's a chapter on priorities in there
and so we're talking about
prioritizations there's an entire
chapter about priorities with several
essays about how to prioritize and
there's a chapter on success redefining
what success looks like for you
because success can't be well if I
accomplish all of my to-do list and all
of a sudden I'm successful or if I make
a certain amount of money that I'm
successful
that's just another type of to-do list
and so there's a chapter on success and
there's also a chapter on stuff in there
and it looks like fallon is is
struggling to deal with some of her
stuff so we give you some practical tips
to address that stuff Sean if you could
reach out to Fallon and give her an
audio book version of essential because
if you enjoy the podcast I think you'll
enjoy the audio book version or if she
wants the the book book version of the
eBook version we're happy to send those
to her as well our next question is from
Kat in Sacramento that's just wondering
if you had any tips on how to worry less
and be a little less than decisive
because that is something that I really
struggle with and I was so much time
worrying about every little thing it
just causes me unnecessary stress so
Ryan it sounds to me like Kat wants to
she want some tips on how to be the way
she phrased it was be less indecisive
and the thing that I think about is to
be less indecisive you have to be more
decisive right right and so instead of
being less indecisive it's really about
how can I be more decisive yeah in my
day to day decisions so I've got some
basic tips because she asked for tips
about worrying less and I promise I
won't spend a whole lot of time on these
because they're basic but they're
important to their thereof they're a
foundation to consider the first off are
you sleeping enough hmm are you
exercising enough I know for me those
two things will radically reduce my
anxiety in fact if I'm feeling really
anxious and overwhelmed one of the
things I'll do is go try to take a nap
it doesn't always work for me but I will
lay down at least and I'll put on my
headphones with a brain FM app and I
will just set it for either 20 30 or 45
minutes and I will just lay there and
let my mind sort of wander it's it's
meditative sometimes awful actually fall
asleep and I'll wake up like oh I'm not
feeling as anxious now because your
breath slows your body calms down even
if you don't actually fall into one of
the stages of sleep you feel a lot
better afterward because it's it's like
defragging your your hard drive and your
mind so to speak so and exercise for me
it can be something just quick and brisk
you know there's a hill right by my
apartment so I'll walk up that hill and
then walk around the block and walk back
down and it gets my heartbeat going for
15-20 minutes or so and then all of a
sudden once you do that you you become
more in sync with with your body
absolutely I just ordered an exercise
bike so that I can make sure I'm getting
my heart rate up and whenever I feel
anxious I'm just gonna hop on that for
20 maybe 30 minutes and that'll totally
change my my state yeah it's good agree
with you more man meditation helps a lot
too
any time any when I'm meditating on a
regular basis I am able to will a be
more decisive but my stress level is is
much more under control yeah meaning I
mean all it does is it allows you to
take and let well this is how it works
for me
it allows me to take a thought that is
really really bothering me causing me
stress interrupting my day and I can
kind of compartmentalize that and say
yes that is a problem that is something
that well maybe it's something I can't
address maybe it's you know we were
talking about my dad last episode maybe
it's something there we're like I
there's nothing I can do I am I am at a
point where it's like I look at that
thought and I say you know what man like
I've done everything I can and I'm going
to go ahead and continue to focus about
going about my day and not let this
angst ruin it ruin the rest of my day
and and if it wasn't for the meditate
and I don't meditate at Legg if if I'm
meditating every days for five to ten
minutes a day sometimes it'll turn into
20 30 minutes but like Moriah now we've
been trying to meditate with each other
for at least five minutes a day and when
I do that I am able to go through that
process a lot easier hands down dude
it's very much like like to sleep I
would think the same scientific
reasoning our friend Dan Harris says one
minute is meditating so like it's it's
it's sort of a gateway into doing longer
I mean Dan meditates for two hours a day
every
you know just phenomenal and I think
it's radically change his life now
meditation is not the miracle drug it is
simply one tool and I like the idea of
the the metaphor of compartmentalizing
something for a second light like the
thoughts about your dad clear they're
not useful right you've already come to
terms with you you've dealt with it
you've had a funeral for the
relationship as you talked about in the
last episode but taking that thought and
sort of put it in this compartment and
then letting that compartment go yeah
and in a way the patient allows you to
let go of those thoughts yeah it allows
me to or it helps me to be more
accepting of life and it helps me to
well basically helps me to lower my
expectations and raise my standards yes
my standard is is like yes I'm not going
to ruminate on stress but I don't expect
that there's gonna be zero stress in my
life and if you don't have time to
meditate
you can't take a nap right now one thing
that really helps me out there's some
science behind this just within the last
few years if you take six deep breaths
oh yeah
and for whatever reason it's six like
that the science shows that minimum of
six you just do though let it out if you
can hold it for you know a few seconds
as well six of those will radically
change your state and it will radically
reduce your anxiety levels now maybe
it's reduced by 30% that's a pretty
radical reduction for Ella I've realized
I was trying to get her to do the six
and she just started hyperventilating
cuz 6 is a big number for a
five-year-old because trying to do six
of anything is like just too much as you
just start it would produce more anxiety
in her come by alright elevated take 60
breaths issues and so now it's like hey
let's take one deep breath let's hold it
in together for a few seconds and then
just let it out and and that really
helps and then if I can get her past one
then it's can we do one more deep breath
if I can get her to do two or three it
often changes her state and then when
she becomes less anxious I become less
anxious another thing that I do when I'm
doing an on creative works if I'm
checking emails or doing phone calls
whatever I wear a wristwatch and I'll
have it on now but with a 22 minute
timer on it so you can set it on your
phone or whatever and it just vibrates
every 22 minutes and I get up and I will
do some form of exercise I'll either do
like 20 squats or I'll do 10 pull-ups or
I will do 50 pushups just something to
get changed my state and I go right back
to working so less than a minute or so
less than two minutes for sure and I go
back to 20 minutes of email or whatever
and that that continues to to help me
with with my anxiety
you mentioned meditation so I think the
thing we need to ask Ryan that we need
to ask at here is the thing that you we
asked each other at the top of this I
what can't what is actually triggering
your anxiety because you might say that
like well I don't know I'm just anxious
all the time I don't know what's
actually trigger my anxiety what's the
decision-making she said right right but
so let's keep going
let's follow that that anxiety to what
what are the specific decisions my guess
is there are certain decisions for her
that are really difficult and so she
puts them off right she's making
decisions every single day so it's not
every decision that is making her
anxious okay maybe she decided to drink
water right now that's not making her
anxious and so what are the decisions
that are making you anxious what are
those triggers and then instead of
hiding from them instead of running away
from them you want to become brave
enough to to run toward them right yeah
and so that worried that worry is just a
word that means fear basically right and
so it reminded me of this this essay
that I've got here somewhere about fear
minimalism kills fear this is on our
website this is an oldie but a goodie
this is from 2010 it's a good woman and
there are some exercises in here I just
want to read so you and I when we first
started the minimalists calm we started
with this 21-day journey into minimalism
which which followed your 21 days of the
packing party and letting go of those
things but along the way there were sort
of these aha moments and one of them had
to do with fear and so this is what we
wrote about that and we'll put a link to
this essay in the show notes as well
we're all afraid of something
some of our fears are obvious spiders
Heights X's other fears are less
pronounced less obvious like the fear of
loss the loss of things the loss of
acceptance the loss of love sometimes
we're afraid to give up what we think we
have fear traps us it prevents us from
growing it prevents us from contributing
to other people it prevents us from
living happy satisfied fulfilled free
lives so think about that for a second
if you're worrying you're you're really
just afraid that worry prevents you from
having a fulfilled free life it gets in
the way of satisfaction quite often yeah
fear is the antithesis of freedom it is
by definition constricting we often hold
onto things because we're afraid to get
rid of them we fear losing those things
because we think we might need them we
don't just fear the loss of these things
though we fear the loss of what these
things might mean to us in some distant
hypothetical future when you say it out
loud
it sounds ridiculous try it I'm afraid
of getting rid of this t-shirt it's
something we actually worry about right
yeah well if I get rid of this I'm
afraid I'm gonna miss it I'm afraid I'm
gonna want it one day I'm afraid that
I'm gonna need it just in the case I'm
afraid that a friend's gonna need it
just in the case right right I'm afraid
that the gorillas t-shirt because it
could have a serious impact on my life
in the future sounds ridiculous right so
there's an obvious question we must ask
ourselves when we're holding on to
something why am i afraid of getting rid
of this now something can be a physical
thing why am i afraid to get but it
could also be like why are you actually
afraid cat why are you afraid of making
a decision mm-hmm what are you actually
afraid of and then saying it out loud
it might seem banal on the surface but
it's actually a great question to ask
when you're faced with these difficult
decisions give it a try so you don't
want to say no to that person what am I
really afraid of mm-hmm
yeah you can't write you good oh no go
for it well you can't write the novel
you've been dreaming of writing why what
are you afraid of I can't learn to play
the instrument
always wanted to play I mean why what
are you afraid if you're gonna be bad of
course you gonna be bad at first
everyone who ever paid that guitar was
bad at first everyone who ever I'm still
pretty bad yes you've picked up a guitar
a lot of times mmm so vine I'm still
pretty bad at it and that's okay and so
it goes on I can't exercise and eat
healthy foods I mean this is something
we tell ourselves I can't I couldn't do
that it's just too difficult it's not
realistic for me to exercise every day
Estonia that made me think man food is
such a like it's the social media it's
another social media it's another
pacifier to anxiety yeah and so I can't
eat healthy why what are you afraid of
right I can't quit the job I hate to
pursue what I'm passionate about why
what are you afraid of I can't fill in
the blank what are you afraid of and I
think it's important to ask that
question the answer this question is
almost always ridiculous I'm afraid
people won't like me anymore I'm afraid
people won't love me anymore I'm afraid
people won't respect me anymore
chances are you have manufactured these
false fears and it is these manufactured
fears that keep you from doing what you
want to do or in the case of our
physical items it's the fear that heat
it's the fears that keep you from
getting rid of the certain things that
have no real value things they don't
have any real meaning in your life we
have good news though fear is a choice
and thus anxiety is often a choice when
you figure out what are those real
what are those triggers right and so I
will I'll put a link to this or shall I
put a link to this in the show notes we
can you can take a look at it we've got
some exercises in here that you can do
to to get rid of those fears
in addition asking that question what
are you afraid of I like that essay the
that's an awesome one dude another good
one I think you actually have it there
the paths oh yes so from cat eye
I totally feel you on this being scared
to make a decision especially the
important decisions am I going to go to
college or am I gonna just try and do
something on my own am I going to go
into debt to buy a big house or am I
just gonna continue to rent I mean there
are these major decisions that are can
be paralyzing because if we make the
wrong decision right it can be
detrimental or it can set us back five
years or so
so I totally I can empathize because
I've been there and and and I'm sure cat
is is experiencing a little bit of that
but cat here's what I will say I don't
know you're gonna read that path as
paths si or not I'm gonna save that for
the the patreon post grip but there's a
separate essay here to talk about - good
yeah let's and we can put a link in for
the past aside by - on you can put a
note in the in the show notes there for
cat to read but you know ultimately cat
like you've got you do have to figure
out a way to trust in yourself she has
to figure out a way to to make these
decisions without without that fear of
the consequence and what I mean by that
is is so she's deciding to buy a house
this can be a good or bad decision yes
there is not it's there's not just a
blanket statement to say well buying a
house is a good or a bad decision right
so the way that cat is going to make
good decisions as she's going to
consider every single possibility every
option she has she's going to consider
how it affects her life how it affects
the people around her how it affects
their lives and ultimately cat like
you're gonna have to make the best
decision given with the given
information that you have yeah Oh God
I wasn't say but here's the thing cat is
sometimes you're gonna make a bad
decision it's gonna happen we all make
bad decisions sometimes yeah but if you
have done everything you can to make the
best decision for yourself and something
goes wrong that's good news yes you get
to learn from it yeah you get to learn
to not make that decision again and
sometimes the the bad decisions can be
really bad sometimes they can be fairly
innocuous right pretty benign and so
here's this essay and other ones called
the worst thing that could happen this
is from our book essential
it says risk scares the crap out of us
and this is gonna be a great question
for cats asses a couple questions in
here many of us associate risk with
failure failure with pain yet we're told
we must take plenty of risks to succeed
the success must be painful right not
necessarily when it comes to challenging
our preconceived notions about risk the
common platitude no question tossed
around by kind
our friends and self-help gurus is
what's the worst thing that could happen
and so so something you think about that
for a second like sometimes what yeah
okay I'm gonna do that what's the worst
thing that can do that was like my
grandpa's biggest piece of advice to me
really yeah he's like any decision that
you have to make think about the worst
thing that can happen right if you can
accept that scenario if you can accept
that consequence then do it right yeah
and so so actually made me do some
really shitty decisions growing up but I
think that's why this essay is helpful
because it helps you ask another
question yes absolutely so truth be told
some risks are fairly benign letting go
of most your material possessions asking
a cute guy or girl for his phone number
writing the first page you have your
phone number Josh yes ice writing the
first page of the book you've always
wanted to write what's the worst thing
that can happen likely nothing at all
like like if you do at and you really
like someone you want to ask with her
phone what's the worst thing it can
happen get rejected yeah literally
nothing happens though right yeah you're
rejected and nothing happens what
happens if you write the first page of
the book and it's terrible nothing
nothing actually have you delete it you
can prove anything happen right there's
no real risk in these harmless endeavors
other risks however probably should
scare the [ __ ] out of you skydiving
purchasing a home quitting your job
what's the worst thing that could happen
well some pretty awful stuff actually
death debt and poverty respectively that
doesn't mean you shouldn't take these
risks and meaning it means you should
approach each risk with logic reason and
intuition
you should peer over the edge before
taking your proverbial leap and if it
makes sense then leap because not
leaping can be a much bigger risk and
the best that goes on it's from our book
essential so Wilson Kat a copy of that
as well what else should we talk to Kat
about Ryan uh you know I just I just
want to reiterate that she's got to
learn how to trust in herself and that's
not an easy thing to do how do you do
that how do you how do you better trust
in you I know how I do it but but yeah I
think for me it's I've learned to trust
myself in the decisions because I have
used that process
giving cat is I will take at any major
decision or even you know minor
decisions if it's something that I'm
wavering on and I'm unsure about like
yes I know that I'm thirsty I'm gonna
have a glass of water that's a pretty
easy decision but but you know given
those harder decisions where we kind of
get paralyzed when they're major life
decisions I'd look at all of the factors
involved whether it's Mariah whether
it's you whether it's the time that I
get to spend with my family the the all
my resources that it affects not just my
money but yes my time my attention like
how was that decision going to affect
those once I take all that into
consideration I can have an informed
decision there's still risk there's
still a possibility that I might be
making the wrong decision but after
applying that formula for years and
years and years I've learned to gain
trust in myself and Kat I still screw it
up it sounds like we still make bad
decisions but I make less bad decisions
I'd make way less bad decisions today
than what I did you know my 25 year old
self yes so it sounds to me like what
what you're getting at there is you have
to make some decisions and I think to
set yourself up for success is make some
relatively easy decisions that you know
okay I have a 90% chance this is the
right decision now ten percent of the
time you're gonna fail I mean you make
ten decisions one of them is gonna be a
failure so you are gonna fail but you're
going to set yourself up for okay now
that I'm making more decisions I'm
leaning into it I'm no longer paralyzed
by indecision I am empowered by my
decisiveness I'm going to be willing to
quickly make these decisions especially
for the benign one so we just went
within the SA what are the benign
decisions where there's essentially no
consequence right now for the big
decisions it does make sense to wait if
you want to buy a house you don't want
to do that overnight right that's it's a
big process for if you want to go
skydiving you really want to think about
that because you could die right if if
you want to quit your job it's just like
well I'm feel like wit my job today I
might as well just walk into my boss's
office today and say screw you I quit
I'm leaving right now that's there are
consequences for that but for most of
the decisions we make every single day
we're treating it like it's life or
death when it's not life or death at all
make those decisions make
them often and the more you make those
decisions the more you'll be able to
trust yourself yeah so so your formula
for trusting yourself is just to
continue to make decisions yes and
either learn from the mistakes or you've
learned to trust yourself because you've
made really good decisions yeah the only
thing I would add to that is make more
benign decisions mm-hmm and and because
what are you doing is you're building up
that muscle so that becomes easier when
the difficult decisions come around and
you trust yourself more now because you
know your ratio has improved maybe it's
just 6040 at first and you're making 60%
good decision 40% bad but over time that
will change 70/30 80/20 yeah no a sudden
now a big decision comes along you're
like oh I can trust myself now because I
know most of the time I'm making a good
decision all of a sudden you start
making those good decisions the worrying
starts to dissipate I've got two more
things for katkat cut out as many
decisions as you can in your life start
wearing one outfit a day
stop try stop deciding where you're
wearing in the morning but you're gonna
want necessary to see unnecessary
decisions cut out as many unnecessary
decisions as possible the other thing
too is on those big decisions go consult
someone go find a close friend confidant
family member mentor someone like this
this apartment-hunting that I've been
going through there are five different
people I talk to about about about the
apartment that Mariah and I are going to
move into and it's because I need as
much information as possible to make the
most informed decision possible at the
same time don't let them make the
decision for course not and I think
that's important because we can't we
can't abdicate our own responsibility so
it's good to get to get other people's
input their feedback that you trust so
do not let them because then you're
actually losing your own decision oh
yeah well yeah and a lot of people put
it on someone else so they can be like
oh well that was your decision right
it's still your own fault for going on
their decisions ya realize that no
matter what decision you make it is
going to be your decision even if
someone else influenced you so you they
don't have to live with it either so
your trusted confidant it really has to
live with that decision and so
ultimately you're the person is gonna be
living in your home or getting rid of
that old cardigan or whatever it might
be you have to determine is this
decision right for me not is it right
for Ryan or Shawn or
or anyone else is it right for me given
my own circumstances cat enjoy that copy
of essential the essay collection with
that with the essay the worst thing that
could happen plus 149 other essays in
there for you
Shana she wants the audio book or the
book book or the e-book then please send
those to her and everyone else we'd love
to hear what you all have to say so if
you have a comment or a tip about
anxiety or worry or stress or discontent
including advice for any of our callers
today then leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also email a voice memo right
from your phone the podcast at the
minimalists calm and stay tuned to the
end of this episode for this week's
listener comments and tips Ryan what
time is it it's time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media may be drawing to put like
some CGI special effects with yeah
imagine that the Greek god Nicodemus is
holding like a lightning bolt Zeus no
you know you have you it's like you oh
yeah it's gonna be an animation of you
with a lightning bolt and you got weird
fantasies Josh yes I do
alright we're on we're on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram at the minimalist
during the lightning rounds where each
of us share a short shareable less than
140 character response we also put the
text of these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pith the answers on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our quotes in one place minimal Maxim's
calm all right our first question is
from charissa she writes in does letting
go of stuff help release anxiety my
parents just sold their house so I'm
back in my home state of Minnesota
minimizing all my old things I can't
justify or afford shipping everything to
California and now my anxiety is all
over the place well here's the thing my
my short answer and then we can we can
unpack this a little bit our material
possessions are a thin our our material
possessions are a physical manifestation
of our inner state amen and so so if
there's too much
stuff outside then there's too much
going on inside get your appendix taken
out that's exactly what I'm saying you
are so wise but but that too much is
perspectival right because the thing if
it's too much for me might be just
enough for Karissa so if there's too
much for you outside if it's stressing
you out that is usually indicated that
there's something going on in here and
it is manifesting outwardly in these
these physical possessions so I would
also say though getting rid of too much
stuff at once can also trigger anxiety
it's like being pushed from a plane
versus skydiving Ryan if you've gone
skydiving before yes one time you're
right and spur-of-the-moment talked into
it wasn't so spur-of-the-moment that you
were just pushed out of the plane it's
true you felt better about the skydiving
experience then if when we got on a
plane this Thursday if I just were to
push you out on our way to Alabama
yes you felt much better because you had
prepared for it accordingly emotionally
psychologically whatever it can still be
terrifying yeah but not nearly as
terrifying as if you weren't prepared
for even if I push you out of the plane
and on the way at Alabama with a
parachute you're still gonna be like
what is going on this is terrifying and
and so I guess what I'm really trying to
say to Chris is is yes you need to let
go
mentally as well you need to be prepared
in here before you let go of the things
outwardly but you'll never be completely
prepared if you're waiting until you're
a hundred percent comfortable with
letting go you'll never let go of
anything because part of the letting go
process is about embracing the
discomfort
Chrissa here's what I'd say the more we
detach from things that don't add value
to our lives the calmer the freer and
the lighter we feel I mean I can't even
tell you man when just going through
that packing party I didn't even get rid
of everything I just packed it all up
right and I already felt much lighter
like sitting in a room and getting out
my laptop that's one of the first things
I unpacked and of course and I got to
unpacked the internet and I'm sitting
there working on the coffee table and
there's
Oh TV in front of me there's no clutter
sitting over in the corner no
distraction no distractions man I mean
it's it is an automat yes absolutely
like the more you let go the freer and
lighter you feel now anything taken too
far can can be bad right so please don't
just run the dumpster and sort of
throwing everything out yeah but when
you let things that's what I'll say is
that when you let things go deliberately
yes the freer and lighter that you feel
yeah because you can do it in a way that
is not intentional you can and that can
be a that could be a huge mistake yeah
and it could produce way more anxiety
now there's some people get that till
aside I mean I think of the couple who
came up to us at Philadelphia and said
their house burned down and and I had a
dumpster fire because they were letting
go of too much stuff they didn't plan
but then they overnight became like
extreme minimalist because they didn't
own anything anymore
now they as a family sort of work
together got past the anxiety and we're
actually a better family because of it
by often we have these these tragedies
these pivot points these inciting
incidents that that are really really
difficult in the moment the car crash
kind of thing but I reminds me of that
you know Matt Nathanson the yeah the
singer-songwriter yeah he's got a song
about the lyric and the chorus is I want
to feel the car crash I want to feel a
calf size and and sometimes we do need
to blow something up so metaphorically
rightly I need to just blow up the
entire now you get to make that choice
if you're making the choice you're doing
so intentionally hmm and and sometimes
it's gonna be easier to let go if you
make that decision and someone as
opposed to someone else making that
decision for you well here's the thing
too is Carissa knows I mean she
obviously know she has to get rid of
some of her things she cannot take
everything in California so whenever we
make the right choices in our lives even
though it's difficult even though it
might be hard even though we feel that
angst of making these hard decisions
whenever we actually do make the right
choice right I mean hands down we feel
more at peace and our minds and our
hearts yeah so Carissa you know what you
got to do yes you have to make these
decisions and yes if you make the right
decisions and you do it deliberately yes
you will feel calmer you will feel freer
you will not experience as much as
anxiety you will release that anxiety
all right our next question is from Mike
the physical feelings of anxiety are
hard to overcome even if you aren't
worrying about something in particular
you have any methods or exercises to
help deal with the physical feelings of
anxiety so this question Josh that Mike
is asking is how can we how can we help
deal with anxiety basically how can we
change our state right so I already
talked about a few of those things
whether it was sleep and you talked
about meditation and exercise and so we
won't be labor those things but yeah
changing your actual physical state
changing your physiology will help a lot
with anxiety nothing helps me more than
changing my physical state right with
respect to anxiety well here's the thing
I mean when we yes when we have anxiety
that is a physical feeling we feel tense
we feel I mean I we get palms get sweaty
butterflies I mean anchor anxiety has
physical feelings so these these things
that we're talking about the meditation
the the taking a nap these are things
that literally change your physical
state right now also keep in mind wood
because his question said the physical
feelings of anxiety as opposed to the
mental feelings of anxiety but here's
the thing there's no difference really
when you get down to it fundamentally
it's all inside our body whether it's
the mental side the physical side and
they are closely tethered together right
yeah you can't you if you solve one you
also solve the other and so so I mean
think about the time when you worked out
the last time you worked out really hard
you were exhausted you went to some like
boot camp with dr. Ryan oh yeah recently
dude I have found in LA like every class
that I go to whether it's at the gym or
yeah Nike did this like pop-up boot camp
Center that's like they they open it
just for the summer that I went and did
SoulCycle I feel like well hey I feel so
out of my league dude like there's this
whole subculture of incredibly fit
people in LA and I'm Way out of my
league when I go to these classes but
the other thing too dude is like well
you know what I could actually let that
get me down sure because sometimes I'm
like oh man like dr. Ryan's looking at
me like oh man Nicodemus sure is lazy
ass or like other people are looking at
me like man he really isn't that
physically fit but ultimately the way I
the way I perceive it and what helps me
to continue to go back is I just kind of
look at it
practicing practicing to take the class
to take the full cab class but with my
practice enough when you're fully sort
of immersed in that it's nearly
impossible to feel anxiety at the level
you would outside of it absolutely
because you're so focused and so it's
about finding that focus and and
exercise really really helps you do that
so does meditation so does sleep being
prepared for the day bye-bye sleep
sleeping adequately and also some diet
stuff but I'm going to talk about
they're in the right here right now
segment but my short pit the answer for
Mike is follow your fear to find the
root of your anxiety and so what I mean
by that is we often as as men especially
yeah we're man yeah on this in this room
isn't that right guys woo yeah we we
hide over there flexing we hide these we
hide the emotion of fear because it is
not considered to be manly and so we use
these other words we say I'm stressed or
I'm anxious or whatever it really just
means I'm afraid I'm afraid of something
and so if you follow your fear you will
you will eventually find the root of
your anxiety and I don't mean just fall
to the first checkpoint lamb oh I'm I'm
anxious because the the light came on in
the car no no I what are you really
afraid of and then can i address that as
opposed to addressing the symptoms well
yeah and fear is it's kind of like anger
meaning it is a surface emotion there is
always something leading to the anger
there's something leading to the fear
yes and yes I totally agree if you can
get to that root we got to kill the root
not just like well I'm gonna snip off
the weed at the top here it's just gonna
keep growing find out what the root is
and address that yeah hey Mike here's my
short answer for you oxygen is anxieties
enemy love it
and yeah the the breathing method that
there are there's a what is his name the
Iceman wim HOF he has a breathing method
Sean podcast Sean I will send you a link
to it but he's got a breathing method
that I mean it'll take you to euphoric
state yeah you could do the the deep
breaths at you the six deep breaths
there's a there's a sniper technique
when I was in Sniper school they taught
on this but I was about doing I was
reading about this this technique that
snipers use where it's like actually
Mariah was telling me about it it's a
it's for breaths or I'm sorry you
breathe in for four seconds as fast as
you can let out for four seconds and you
do that four times okay my point is yeah
my point is is that Mike it doesn't
matter you know the way that you the
method that you choose choose a method
and stick with it the breathing method
is definitely help meditation helps
sleeping helps but yeah these are all
tools tools that you can use to help
decrease your anxiety in the moment help
decrease your anxiety PS we have one
more question this question is from
Aaron how do you deal with worrying over
possibly not doing the right things in
the right place at the right time oh my
god I'm anxious we'll just reading that
question should we just be happy with
what we have and not let fantasizing
over better things get in the way of our
current focuses and man I think I got
quite a few answers on this because I've
always had quite a few focuses and that
was part of the problem so if you'd like
to hear our answer to that question you
can listen to this week's PostScript
episode over at the minimalist private
podcast exclusively for our patreon
supporters that's why it's a private
podcast so if you want to support our
show and help keep this podcast a
hundred percent advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimalist
private podcast feed includes our
monthly ask the minimalist anything
episodes unreleased recordings of our
live events we're headed out on the road
for these live events coming up soon and
the entire back catalogue of our past
private episodes once you become a
supporter you'll receive a personal link
to our private podcast feeds of the
plays and your normal podcast player and
as a patreon supporter you also receive
access to our monthly live stream videos
they're called ask the minimal as
anything live stream videos as well as
first access to tickets to all of our
live events before those tickets are
available to the general public you can
find all the details and all the good
stuff over at the minimalists com
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode often the
correct decision is glaring the right
path is illuminated clear for miles
obvious to everyone whenever this is the
case seize the opportunity take the
right path okay now it's time for our
added value portion the shows or each
talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently and I just
want to talk about something really
simple sometimes we talk about products
hmmm that I find value in and especially
experiences whether it's music or I'm
like first I went to a concert when I
was back in the zoo for a couple days
with Phoebe Bridgers who I've
recommended her album before mmm but it
was just we asked at the top hat right
this is not my added value but well at
least I could talk about it because it
was the strangest awesome concert I've
ever been to
Phoebe Bridgers music is a beautiful bad
dream it's like sad but the most
gorgeous kind of said it was like a
lovely show but most of the kids who
were there she's I don't know 22 years
old or something
they're kids who were there in the crowd
like is it like fits in at all
Fitzsimmons similar yeah yeah yeah more
more despair that his music his music
more despair that his media oh wow yeah
yeah but it's but it's beautiful too
his music William Fitzsimmons is also
I've never heard before I'm just like
trying to hers is slightly more awesome
someone who kind of reminds me of yeah
yeah yeah so they're certainly in the
same I wouldn't be surprised if they did
a song together in the near future yeah
but like because you you go to concerts
like at the top out or whatever and it's
Gregory Allen has a call for Joshua
James or someone where you're like
you're into it and like the crowd feels
good but her whole set like she did her
album which is like 10 songs on it and
two covers on that was her whole set but
the whole thing is fairly somber and so
the crowd was sort of into it but in a
somber away
it was the strangest sort of experience
but it makes me think of like Adele
concerts it was um I remember like
watching these highlights like and they
specifically took the highlights of
women crying oh the concerts and like it
was like this I figure where I saw this
but it was talking about how like it's
just a bunch of you know people coming
together and crying about past
relationships but they really enjoy the
experience never really happens at our
show I'm thinking of back to 2014 we
were giving a talk and you were giving
your talk in Salt Lake City and there
was a woman on the balcony who passed
out the middle of your talk yeah she
just got overheated though yeah well I
mean you are pretty hot Ryan all right
come on Phoebe keep on right that's not
my added value but we're gonna go see
she's gonna open for the National when
we go see the National September 21st I
think that's a Greek Theatre in LA so
you'll get to see her set then when she
opens up for the National awesome but um
the thing that I'm gonna recommend for
anxiety is walking quickly in the Sun
one one thing we didn't write we didn't
talk about today his son and son is like
this free medicine like water is that we
neglect it resets our circadian rhythm
so getting out for getting in some sort
of Sun 15 minutes of Sun when you first
wake I like to go stretch outside like
on the patio and I'll just do my morning
stretches and get a little bit of that
Sun or just go up 15 minutes and walk
because you can't replicate that indoors
you mean you could have we have the
brightest light above our heads right
now if you're watching this on the
YouTube channel the brightest light up
here this is not even close to what the
Sun produces I mean it's a totally
different world you're smirking yes it
feels crazy bright is it does yeah you
go outside on a cloudy day and does it
feel as harsh as this this light feels
harsh to me right now yeah and and I got
us on a cloudy day you're still getting
more Sun than if you were to be cooped
up indoors so walking briskly for 15
minutes in the Sun radically changes my
anxiety level so that is that's my added
value is go take some free medicine take
some welcome Sun you know what I got
something written down here that
nothing to do with anxiety so I'm gonna
call an audible I'm gonna recommend
Eckhart Tolle ease the power and now
mm-hmm it is a woooe book I'm just gonna
like preface it with that but dude it's
for me it's so good and you're
practicing that because we're usually
allergic to the whoo well I like the
whoo
uh-huh I like exploring it uh-huh I
don't buy any of it there you go
I love the oh that's I actually though I
was telling someone this the other day
like the my belief system that I haves
in um I wouldn't share it with anyone
like that the actual beliefs that I that
I have and that I go by mm-hmm they are
out loud they're insane yeah spaghetti
monster
right so I I understand that it's like I
don't believe in my beliefs or what a JP
say on our podcast we I have my beliefs
and I hold them really close I believe
he said have your beliefs but don't
believe your believe yes and that's
exactly what I do and and Jordan you
know JP Sears
are you familiar with his work he was on
one of our pocket you'd really like his
stuff talk to Jordan here yeah you would
like it because the the the his comedy
is like right up your alley it's so good
sure but but my point is is that the
power of now it is very woowoo II and
some of the things I've taken away that
I did I that I believe that I don't
believe in it is it has helped me
understand that voice in my head that's
constantly causing the anxiety that's
constantly criticizing me that's
constantly judging myself or maybe it's
judging others but that that internal
voice that we all have like I have never
looked at it the same since reading that
book the power of now and here's the
thing too about the movie stuff dude
it's really fun to believe this is so
much fun to believe here's a gateway
into that if you really like me and
you're like I can't get into the woowoo
stuff Sam Harris who's in our
documentary he has this of this video
someone did like a voiceover video of a
talk he gave about essentially the power
of now I think it's called there is only
now Sean if you can find a link that's
on YouTube we'll put a link to that in
the show notes as well so you get to
choose you can do the power of now or
there's only now if you just want a
five-minute sort of
yeah him talking about there really is
only now yeah and I think I think it'll
accomplish the same thing depending on
what your proclivities are yeah yeah I
mean obviously the power and I was gonna
go much deeper into it but but yeah if
you're not like for me when I read the
movie stuff like it is it doesn't bother
me because well a like I respect other
people's values and beliefs so I try not
to cache judgment on that and I'm just I
am able to compartmentalize the okay
like I understand that's how they
interpret this thing that happens in
life and that's their explanation for it
and I'm glad that they see it that way
and then I can keep moving past it but I
don't have to like stop and like tweet
them and be like no no you should hear
on page 17 that and yeah it's it's all
depends on your style I guess you don't
feel need to correct everyone all the
time yeah absolutely well well also
because I don't know anything 100% right
you know what works for you that's what
we tend to share on my podcast website
films whatever alright let's move on the
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist I said I had some follow up
from previous episodes so here's a jfm
health update so at the beginning of
this month so we're typing this on July
17th right didn't you send me a text
that said you can cut diamonds with your
dick now or something I did that's
exactly what I said that wasn't the only
thing in the text but so so I have this
I mean I haven't been dealing with
younger Bynum listened to the health
problems episode episode 138 I did with
my doctorate if you want to dive deep
into what health problems I've had and
I've been feeling great this year in
general I just so much better I can tell
dude I mean all year I've been feeling
great I've addressed all the probably
son man la doctors
well the silly ladies well yeah the move
my lady
from from Montana yes and so the the the
things I've been going through have been
really anxiety producing but more than
anxiety they were despair inducing
and I remember a couple years of three
years ago I really felt like two years
ago I felt some serious despair on my my
35th birthday and it was sort of the the
nadir of this whole thing where I was
just feeling so bad and since then I've
worked really hard in the last six
months I feel better than I have and
maybe five seven years but then this
month I feel better than I have in a
really long time and so earlier this
year I did this 10-day fast I only
lasted six days because it made me
really sick it's a it's not a real fast
as a fast mimicking protocol to detox
fast by doctor named dr. Walsh and I you
do all these sort of you do this weird
soup and onion and garlic soup you're
saying pretty much is there anything
else in it there's a bunch of spices and
and it basically it has the enzymes that
help you detox from heavy metals and a
few other things in addition to the
chelating therapy and everything I've
done to deal with those heavy metals but
then this this well the this month I I
did it again on my doctor's
recommendation try for four or five days
so therefore four days this fast
mimicking diet detox and afterward while
I was listening to that I was I heard a
Jordan Peterson on Joe Rogan's podcast
and he was talking about how he had been
on the carnivore diet
for a lot about this recently man and my
chiropractor was just tell me and he
looks like he looks great like don't get
me wrong but he also was telling me how
awesome he feels yeah and so I but he
and his daughter have had some serious
autoimmune issues which I certainly had
different ones from me what exactly is
an autoimmune anything that triggers an
immune response in your body sublimation
yeah information is a big one eczema is
a youn disease chemical sensitivities
which is what I have autoimmune and so
there are a bunch of things just
whatever makes our immune system over
react to something in the normal
environment is basically an autoimmune
response and so it's just my natural
state man just overreacting to
everything yeah but your your immune
system
oh and so I in I mean I I've also had a
significant amount of gut issues you
know gut health issues right and so I
after this four-day fast over the last
two weeks you've got a stomach
transplant no I've been eating nothing
but meat and greens that is well and
oils percentage-wise
no I don't have any percentage like I
was not like 60% meat 30% greens 10%
olive oil no no so whatever I'll do
olive oil or I'll do coconut oil can you
do like avocados and suffer just flat up
oils you I don't know yet and here's why
so in these in these two weeks I've been
eating meat so organic chicken or steak
and green leafy greens and then some
sort of oil and I've also been eating
well drinking a little bit of coffee
each day and 100% dark chocolate
occasionally and that's it that is the
extent of my entire diet I'm not first
off I'm not recommending this for anyone
I'm not saying you should do this as
well what I'm saying is the clarity of
mind that I feel is better than I have
in decades awesome the amount of energy
I have is stupid I mean it is like we
finished that Phoebe bridges concert was
11:45 p.m. now you know me I am tired by
6:00 p.m. yeah 11:40 follow them like I
can go home right now do some emails I
could get on a exercise by I can do
whatever I want right now I am like
fully energetic and I'm actually
sleeping a little bit less right now
with more energy I'm not taking the
afternoon naps like I don't feel like I
need them I don't have that crash
throughout the day ever
at all I'm never feeling tired except
one day I added eggs and avocado to my
my breakfast oh wow and it destroyed me
for about two days Wow
all of a sudden I was like lethargic and
I felt it like here in my head and it
was just it was crazy now the reason I'm
doing this I'm working with my doctor to
do it I think that's another thing
that's important is after 90 days I'm
gonna do a blood panel to compare my
blood results so he has the sort of
he has indexed results of seven or eight
thousand different people and so my
blood last I got drawn when I was 36 and
I had the blood of a 47 year old mm-hmm
now a lot of that has to do with
inflammation so I have a lot of
inflammation but ever since this month
I feel differently I look thinner I'm
not I haven't lost like a bunch of
weight or anything but like the
inflammation is gone my knees aren't
creaky how they used to Bowl I don't
feel achy how I was feeling all the time
and believe me I get it this diet is not
for everyone my partner Rebecca
essentially has the exact opposite diet
she is basically a vegetarian and so I
will sit down and eat a meal together
and I have a I'm food as medicine
I'm never hunger anymore I'm never but I
make sure I get enough calories so again
2,500 calories a day or more and so I'm
not depriving myself of food and I'm
still taking the supplements that I
talked about on on episode 138 but I've
the proof is how I feel right now I feel
amazing now I know I'll probably get
sick at some point and this this is not
some sort of miracle cure for me I'm
just saying I feel significantly better
and as soon as I have more data but I've
done a blood test I'll see if it's
actually improved you know my internal
health as well that's awesome man yeah
Mariah I forget what what nourish
balance thrive what diet they have her
on right now but that's the next the
next approach is the carnivore diet
basically and so I'm not technically on
a carnivore diet because I'm eating
other things other than meat right
amount of greens I got a salad this this
morning was just greens and a little bit
of oil so it's not the carnivore diet
it's kind of like I squat or die ish
meat and greens that's what I call it
because that's really what it is I also
have some coffee and some oils and
occasionally some dark chocolate 100%
dark chocolate so cool yeah that's
something to keep in mind and and I'm
not encouraging anyone to try that I
just wanted to share that and let you
know that I'm feeling better than I ever
have and I know that I'm gonna get
started getting messages from vegans and
other people you got to try this you got
to try this you got to try this believe
me I've tried virtually every die this
one seemed the most crazy to me so I
just like didn't
I didn't go down his path other diets
have really helped me out I've gone I'm
primarily a plant-based diet really
helped me because I cut out the
processed foods my life that certainly
helped right when I did paleo that
helped because I brought some meat back
in my life and increased my energy
levels this current diet
I don't know how sustainable it is I
don't how long it'll last
we can go back most of our food episode
two right rich role and I in you we're
all talking about how how we each have
different needs and that's why Rebecca
can thrive on her current diet on her
carbohydrates and she can do CrossFit
and all these other things and for me I
get really tired when I eat a bunch of
carbohydrates or even just a little bit
what else we have on right here right
now Ryan you're not gonna be a dodge
ball tonight I'm not because we're
finishing trying to film this new
documentary well Matt and I will be
there
well you don't have any kids yeah and so
we're tonight we're yesterday you filmed
at your house great a segment for this
new documentary it's called the
minimalist lessons now and it's built
around this talk that we gave last year
but then there's all this other stuff
we've done these monologues we've got
this this product this widget that we're
talking about we're talking about
consumerism we went to Dayton Ohio and
filmed in this abandoned beautiful him
all he does with that footage so we've
got so good all this great footage with
Matthew Vella and we're going out to my
house tonight to film a dinner that
we're having together the five of us
yeah it's what we do typically man we
have a dinner and Matt films it that's
right
I don't know why he needs more footage
of this why why he always tells us not
wear clothes it's strange but uh
hopefully that'll be out by the end of
the year so stay tuned to that if you're
on our email list over at the
minimalists comm you'll be the first to
know about where it will be and when it
will be coming out and yeah I can't play
dodgeball tonight that's unfortunate but
we do speaking of dodgeball yes dude I
have like my shoulder like right now
it's not too bad dude
but like I didn't realize just from
playing 40 I mean the games are only 45
minutes
was an hour but yeah yeah it's yeah and
we're not throwing balls the whole time
either right but lay the few that I
throw man like if you don't if I don't
throw it properly like it totally
several days God screws up my shoulder
several days for me yeah yeah but it
gets better each week I found yeah I'm
taking three weeks off because we're
traveling for the tour if you have any
dodgeball tips hit me up on Twitter at
Ryan Nicodemus tips and we do have some
exciting new news you've heard us
reference some one random person named
Jordan this disembodied person yes I
think if you're watching the YouTube
channel right now he'll probably flash a
picture of himself right now right we
have a new team member what's going on
here oh look ladies and gentlemen its
Jordan Moore so if you're listening to
this which 99% of you are listening to
it then you can find him over yeah he
has such good intros and outros you can
find him on Instagram Jordan no more but
it's KN o W mor dude you're no more
super so we we went through this process
about 50 people submitted mm-hmm
some sort of real to us right yeah and
then we move 19 people on to the second
round of the filmmaker round to game
show where the minimalists are hiring a
filmmaker and 19 people made it through
and they were all great like I would
have felt good about with at least a
dozen of those people like absolutely
yeah wow these are great people and then
we we selected four people to move on to
the next round where they had to edit
last week's episode and do different
graphics and stuff like that and we
accidentally screwed up the footage that
Jordan had to edit and somehow he fixed
it because he's a ninja that's right and
he's just a super talented filmmaker
storyteller artists and check out his
work you Jordan no more.com
or find him on instagram we'll put a
link to all that in the show notes yeah
well we're so lucky to have you on the
team man yeah so thanks so much for
doing this it's funny though I was I was
telling Jordan like how you know you'll
hear people say something like oh I wish
could hire them all or I wish everyone
could have one or like I truly wish like
those top ten people we could hire them
all yeah we probably will work with a
couple of them in the in the future but
but man like what what a freaking honor
to be able to go through all those
awesome submissions and talent and and
we had the cream of the crop has risen
and Jordan yes welcome to the team man
we are so grateful more so so stay tuned
YouTube channel youtube.com slash the
minimalists we're obviously gonna do
more video podcast and now you can see
what's got the three angles and we're
gonna do some we're gonna cut up some of
these high and do some quick episodes
and so you'll see a lot more video stuff
well also work on maybe some webseries
some voiceover things we've got a lot in
store and as your de Nez a lot of good
ideas for us as well so we're gonna do a
lot more with video stuff it's the one
area where we've been deficient these
last eight years other than the
documentary which is the most popular
thing we've ever done and now we'll be
able to do a lot more video stuff short
form things video essays more visuals
things that are gonna add value to your
life and we've got someone to help us
tell those stories produce some
meaningful creations for you so stay
tuned to our YouTube channel for that
and oh a shout out to Katie and
Alejandro and Devon and Thea rounded out
the top 5 for us I mean just some
amazing people I would have felt good
about any of you I'm grateful you took
the time to submit I'm grateful for
everyone who took the time to submit and
we are here now
Jordan welcomes the team my friend all
right what else we have going on right
now
oh yeah we're looking for some more
questions about sex love business jobs
and sleep so if you have those you'll
move to the front of the line if you
call up with a question we've got some
special guests coming on for that and if
you'd like these show notes in your
inbox you always hear us talking to
podcast Sean about the show notes just
go to the minimalists com enter your
email address at the top we'll e-mail
you the show notes anytime a new episode
comes out also if you're watching this
on youtube the videos on youtube come
out a day early so if you want to get
this podcast a day earlier you can find
the video version on youtube on Mondays
and one other bit of good news so last
year we did the packed bag project yeah
and it was it was this weird experiment
where we essentially encourage people to
not buy some talked about yet talk about
just just back back peddling a little
bit or taking a step back a decision
that we had to make to to to makes a
physical item Duden leggy that was a
very tough it was anxiety-producing for
me a little bit like okay is this the
right decision are we doing the right
thing and I mean that the the packed bag
is an example of something where yes
like I took all the factors into
consideration talk to many people you
and I had many conversations about it
and we came up with a decision to go
ahead and do the packed bag but with the
caveat of trying to talk people out of
buying absolutely meaning hey you prot
that the the the only way that we
promoted it was hey you probably don't
need a new bag right but we've had
thousands of feet over not thousands we
had over a thousand people reach out to
us since the documentary came out said
hey where'd you get your bag and the
truth was there only 300 of them ever
made and we would take it as a joke dude
like at first yeah oh you watched our
documentary and you want to purchase
that bag we have failed you we are so
sorry right like we've just encouraged
you to buy this back right but within
what we realized you know what like I've
been using this bag for seven years I've
gotten more value out of this item than
any other one individual item because we
travel so much right and so I travel
ever in fact I was at the Bozeman
Airport last week and and this guy walk
I take a picture with you and I'm like
yeah sure and I sent my bag down he's
like I bet you're only travel with one
bag I'm like yeah I've heard the jokes
before man like like I could tell he's
getting ready to go down the road of
life I just give polite laughter I had
someone walk up to me the other day I'd
like some lemons in my hand so I'm a
very minimalist amount of lemons I just
give him the old oh yeah so the good
news is they finally started like people
started receiving the first early
backers we did a IndieGoGo campaign with
it and it was wildly successful in the
sense that a lot of people
we talked in we talked out of it didn't
buy the bag and why I was saying it's
successful is now I'm getting these
reviews back from people where it says I
really like my husband loves his bag or
my wife loves his bag I really should
have ordered too but I was when you guys
you said to be really deliberate and
question whether or not we actually
needed this bag and so it worked I guess
so if anyone's interested in seeing that
you can go to go pack calm it's Gopa
Katie calm you can see the bag but you
probably don't need a new bag so don't
buy it unless you actually think you'll
get value from yeah talk about anxiety
inducing to man like just you know the
the responsibility of putting a product
into the world and like you know the
waste and the labor put into it and then
the quality once it arrives to someone's
place and dude Malcolm Fon ta has just
flawlessly executed from beginning to
finish an amazing product that dude I'm
I'm really proud to talk people out of
buying it alright that's that's almost
in here if you have a comment for this
episode you can leave it on youtube we
that's where we do check the comments
like I said early episodes come out on
Monday is a day early Ryan you got
anything else for us yeah man I got all
these voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hey Josh
and Ryan my name is Jennifer I'm calling
from Pittsburgh PA I just had a comment
on the collecting a podcast episode for
trophies
I usually toss them but for metals
they're easy to store and they make
great Christmas ornaments that way you
still have them and you still get to see
them once a year and they store really
great because they're small and they're
flat hi Josh and Ryan this is Emily from
Oklahoma City
I had a tip I feel like you guys have
been getting a lot of questions about
journals and keeping things and I know
that the gratitude journals are very
popular nowadays instead of keeping a
traditional gratitude journal I started
writing on my mirror in my bathroom with
dry erase marker every night before I go
to bed so after I brushed my teeth I'll
write down three things that brought me
joy or that I'm grateful for that
in that day and then that way I go to
sleep and the next morning when I wake
up the first thing I see are those
things that I'm grateful for starts off
the day and a great mindset and it's one
way where you can just erase it and do
the same thing the next night and it
doesn't build up into any journals or
anything hi guys this is Stephanie from
Harrison Ohio I'm calling in regard to
your main first episode with the ritual
about food I had a comment and an added
value my comment is I was really nice to
hear from somebody who has began about
keeping things simple because I've
transformed over the past few months
through my vegan journey and I've
discovered the same thing that just
keeping things simple when it comes to
food makes things a whole lot easier
it's not as hard as what you might think
in the beginning but in my beginning
phase of becoming vegan I did find a
blog and a cook and Baker who really
adds a lot of value to my my recipes and
what I chose to add to my daily intake
of food and her blog is a minimalist
Baker right yes that she has the least
amount of ingredients the least amount
of tools to make each recipe and I have
not had a bad recipe from her blog yet
alright Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine or
you can send a voice memo right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm if you all leave here with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus